tractor you from the stone troops of
individuals bugs in white here the right headlight does not
read
beyonce lyrics.
he drinks so much poison and set a goal
road plan against the background
next
thing
version statement very
negative sins of the world's principles
pole cluster and wen's store
on
the very out of the sandbox here the kiss
will be
inconsistent so so low
more
about api youtube alkana egor varianov he
will ask corrigan enter I stand it is
spoiled because of your fence route
welcome igor rodionov who
as the minister of defense of russia
is in the pentagon for the first time in the united
states  america in a new capacity as a
warehouse channel formation a team from which he
gathered under did not dare after we
had negotiations in the morning we found out
that we had common opinions on some
very important issues in the game I
sent everyone and the prospects
for preventing bela'dia on  world im
about vanga is your pediatrician worth it we
agreed on the same as our p  residents in
Helsinki and that the prospects for the development of
Russian-American relations will be
much better if Russia and America
work together
such a strong jumps in bosnia drum and
bass, maybe we will kill
another Urfa prize, our cooperation on a
visit showed that what we can
achieve if hand in hand  hand we will
work in the direction of
maintaining peace in the game it is you growing
seduce get around the essence of the jack nuclear
force ford we agreed that both the
united states of america and russia
should continue to move towards the
reduction of strategic forces
.  exist.ru service to keep silent fifty
percent in this country song he caught and
compared to the START-1 treaty the
START-2 treaty will lead to a 50 percent
reduction in armaments in both countries
he is called on by Olsen applejack flags dash
new to the end from there he thought the warfare
situation and President Clinton  and President
Yeltsin announced that they will
seek further
arms reductions after the ratification of the
START-2 treaty by the State Duma of Russia and on the
front of the tory contract bell biv cheese and
add it to the sea case
konstantin and the channel of the region km asus
fractions diko andrey mishin that he and
Mr. Rodionov and I today announce
the start of construction of a new installation
for the destruction of containers and
engines
and software, and which will lead to a reduction of 400 to
units of
intercontinental ballistic missiles,
then loops of tea platforms for one gave
confiture lockheed martin lips beat on and
generally knuckles mlm turned workers  in
projects by aleksandr & dan dan she is
elastic
further we talked about the object about
construction of a
$52.4 million facility that will
provide employment opportunities for Russian
workers, a contract signed with
Lockheed Martin and funded
by the Meadows program and
frequent buyer of
Lycopene Sanders.
this setting will be very important for the
reduction of armaments on the basis
of the START-2 treaty, we have an idea with
whom the shark of the cost dance has
decided on the need to reduce the
reduction of chemical weapons because they
pose a threat and Milan has a lot of
problems and this radar antenna canvas was
a line of flour  in a penny and again in
accordance with the agro lane for
lugger we are building a special installation
for the destruction of chemical weapons in the Urals by
faith it costs 100 cents
Wells
even
buy after and views we also
agreed that we should continue
our dialogue despite the differences
in our views mastered the reputed trifles
pause magical we are worth collected
cause on the clouds still full-scale
get to the Volga watching the chin-chin
being the leading countries of the world
Russia and the United States of America are well
positioned and can commit themselves to lead the
rest of the world
towards reducing
tensions.  on the lantern a check with a tight blood
number and it is here infodiv futures kashin
vault our finger in brochu option
is ideally positioned as
minister rodionov so i
take this commitment seriously and i
look forward to having further
discussions with minister rodionov in
europe in russia and in the united states  the states will
forge his for a little jaw in the city
could a cool one and a half pile slave of jesus
from here smelling puppies we
agree that our military can work even
more and bundles both
bilaterally and
through partnerships for
peace lotte [ __ ] is such as  the mammoth he
and the list of documents in in the worst you
sea and now a few words about the specific
agreements that we that we came
this morning just
vinnie jones taipan got club groves
first new joint statement about the
military dream you drink
too much basic frame will be photo was very  your chip should
poppins the dacha and you its a bedbug or fashion on
stilts immediately bu  siness and finance
this gives us the basic framework for developing
relations between our ministries
and this year we will cooperate in
more than 100 training visits
and activities related to the preparation of
training
sakina  activities for
cooperation in the field of
mutual threat reduction, their share of the
cometary they went and logging in action
whether you are on ios little things cleared
sochi leshchinsky to our thinned out just small
things armies in black stas
and thirdly our new commitments to
intensify
regular interaction between higher
educational institutions
national  turnover of the national
defense universities of the usa and the military
academy of the
russian general
staff
iphone military reform aru polishing
anti-spread first court
sense pro tbd pauses important sprinkle
peacekeeping processes after late
trifles cutting off information farsane of
what and military education in the 21st century on
al-bait our minnows tigers .
and now I will ask Minister Rodionov
to speak in front of this audience,
thank you, dear Mr. Minister,
dear Mr. Minister,
ladies and gentlemen, there is
no reason, I think that the visit of the official
delegation of the Ministry of Defense of Russia to the
United States of America began
dynamically and specifically aikan ice cider
dd z of death and shell delegation of rage
in my us 3 defiance beasts now
start n.d.
he smokes and shoes are under
consideration the
development of relations in the region between
russia and the united states of america a
natural and natural process of
normalization of relations between our
countries
after the end of the cold war and visits
like this are an important part of
our interaction
do it development of relations in tamil
actress who are  between your nd it is necessary
states of america is a body and began the
process of
automation of relations between all
countries of today and ethical yard the
main purpose of my visit to the United
States is to work together with the American
side to reach
agreements in principle
aimed at expanding bilateral
defense cooperation in the spirit of
pragmatism  and openness on a wide
range of issues that
determine the current state of
dynamically developing relations between the
military departments of our
states  f principle game mind which
are and extension of ballet went defense
in captions
andy spiritists pragmatism and open
range of issues which they
determine the conditions of dynamic or
[ __ ] penguins chance between minutes
park view hoo countries today there is
every reason to say  that Russia and the
United States have many points of
contact in many areas of
mutually beneficial military
cooperation, I have reasons for to believe that
your nd people states of the lot of coins
of contact he is the manager of actions of tortured
advantech with which we are optimistic
about the possibility of a long-term
cooperation in the field of reforming the
armed forces and training of personnel, we also place
great hopes on
joint work in planning
peacekeeping operations within the framework of the
UN, and both of them and their conduct in
optimistic obata helped the body in long
term papers in the field of reforming
land forces and think of  me later
staff great houses and connect w  ith issue a
combine work in planning of
persons with andy frames framework
algorithm chance vat and
I think that there is no such problem on which
it would be impossible for the head of the military
departments of our countries to reach an
understanding
or at least slightly bring our positions closer,
unless of course here this is
extremely seriously and responsibly
in  the name of
our states and at their core 7 cis
sponsor approach to common problems are
things that we don't have any of them
heeded at your call o rad list joe
all class positions
we are satisfied with the results of the annual
meetings of the bilateral working group on
contacts in the pacific area  the first
meeting of the
Russian-American advisory
group on defense issues as a result of the pit of the
planned it delegation he nova ben over the
past year and a half
way series white otters sounds of enemy
tanks to the hospital rockin' groups he
contacts in the zone of those and fig dinner
wi-fi tinkov machine  american consult
these bands he defense and shoes and
weathered the floors and n  e lx7 jes in a single last
& tim ons we intend to expand the
Russian-American dialogue on
cooperation in the areas of preventing the
proliferation of weapons of mass
destruction and also to resume
consultations within the framework of existing
agreements to prevent
dangerous military activities un
intention is lover attention in this
field of proliferation of  web
ansoff miss destruction winding new
consultations would be dandy frameworks exist
in agreement on prevention of money once
nice activities
good prospects for our
cooperation i see the area of adaptation of Russi
n servi
emen being retired as well as in the use o
peacekeeping conti
gents of russia and the united states in op
rations united natio
s  and about
axes will include prospects of all a
corporation in the field of adaptation
of dolls 40 min hua cart lady's charm
minutes resources
bird & shoulder walked
so we can say that
our relationship is
filled with concrete content and
inspires hope for the future it is important
to develop and strengthen
this trend of this particular task and my colleagues and I
dedicate my visit
thank you for your attention
inquiry batch she althing z oo relations
a very  promising and you are not the winners
vest in dense weight with demain objects and in
my visit Sonya were a match
maybe then we will hear questions
that the press has
I would like to ask a question
there was a message in Washington this
week that as a result of the failure of the
strategic Russian forces
an emergency system has been triggered
for emergency preparation of
strategic nuclear forces
x1 is
it true and is it possible that
Russian nuclear missiles can be
launched by accident and without
permission,
I have not heard about this information, but
as the Minister of Defense of Russia I am a
non-working day and all 24  hour
line replacement defense of rage but is my
office not  a walking
track how
reliable the security system works
to
ensure the
control and security of the entire
strategic nuclear forces and nuclear
weapons and twenty four
such articles of irresponsible people
who are trying for
1 minute who are trying to warm up
public opinion the times itself and to the
question you all so if statements of yourself and
in the responsible individual's build a hit
by public api it I must tell
you ladies and gentlemen we
are now feeling great funding difficulties
but
for all the difficulties, the
financing of the security of nuclear
weapons and the control system
remains unchanged in the design for the
worse, but about the same level of seidak and you
with the experiment video experience on
short aegis infants in fine and a loan
for this bad before us quickly they
knew cleo forces of  dust removal of an
den with yes  100 of funny girls at here with me
is the commander of the
Pacific Fleet,
Admiral Kuroyedov from the world, can confirm this
from that command of the Vinci fund of the pacific fleet
for the fleet, and most recently
, the
commander-in-chief of the
strategic missile forces and general of the
army sergeev n hiking proof was visiting the United States  dictate
us in mmo worlds and recently issued z
oo command chief to stand up and checks
sale for system to donate estates and he
can also confirm my words at
least not by myself
anyway we will do our best to
[music]
reliability security with
all  the difficulties that Russia is experiencing
did not decrease and avanti a gap that we
build a certain pass able to ensure that
we say party and protection of all a new
playing the arsenal of everyday decrease in the
appeal of the support of Itar Tass
, the prospects for NATO expansion were discussed
and whether it was possible to bring positions closer to both
minister
consecrated  wild paten and more of letters
extension  eats word and hells prospects
of a discussed this issue without any problems until
mine is resolved I have my disk ost here yet in
it is already be gold only
during each meeting with American
colleagues with
an American colleague and with
NATO defense ministers
I try to clarify the
attitude
russia to this question and read have
may american about europe account parts are
right to explain to machines upgraded it
without still very sick for russia very
worrying for russia and tsar boris sans sans
de fontaine full looking good today
just in moscow there is a meeting of the minister of
foreign affairs and  to the general sweater of
nato the master with alan of the judges take
him the mask is killed the wine channel shortening to
find mr sollano and your field -3
primakov where the
issues of the
agreement the
mayor of berlin lasta charter will be finally agreed upon which would
suit russia and nato egripment to a greater extent
yes here the seed was the thread of his andrash
there is a maximum of extend,
but in general, in general, I
personally
think and will be with  read that this is probably a
mistake bad in general how to expand and
advance nato to the east and to the citadel
for a dsm steak expand find eastward and
this problem can cause some
damage to our relationship vat on pancake we
sheathed a demic aloe relationship
8 age bolt get ready
for the minister of defense  russia because the us
secretary of defense and
you are so important style will say
edward prospect retired now clipping
stands here win you play warm the
question sounded like this we discussed or
made some progress answer yes
we discussed we reached this
state we both agree and disagree
we agreed to
disagree with
sergiy
your court to which you could also not
reach an agreement please tell me a
little bot about the question that
was asked regarding the security of
america and russian nuclear forces and
I'm
all this
comedy with the order of the exit 1 class
contract to the whole I probably this
question  with the commander of strategic
weapons who was in tes  no connection,
everything with his Russian colleague
extensa is quite controversial -
it becomes more stupid than conversations and you
are a force android support in
show and I didn’t discuss this issue with you this morning
and it seems
that Russia’s strategic nuclear forces
are under serious control
I’m also trying to get expenses, I
’m trying to give a hair of leaks to the Waffen-ss, these are
bolts on scrolling through India, I was fooled and the
question tormented the question is to
reduce the strategic forces that
the United
States of America currently possess Russia to the tactical
level of tactical in bulthaup
agreements and the situation here will be we
glue the factory  his start in adsense daughter
come out of the matches your nose substances
baloga give before we express the hope that the
Russian Duma will ratify the START
27 treaty so that we can quickly
start discussing
the START 3 treaty, which will lead to a
further reduction of strategic
weapons in both countries, I would like to
add ready  Sorry
American intelligence is working and I
also highly appreciate the
professionalism
next to
Minister Queen, a direct connection of the hives,
although go out to fanning by reducing the defense
if something like this is known, I
am sure that the minister will always
call and say rodionov
somewhere
there, somewhere there is data that
[music]
weakening control system sour candy
comandon country reliability and I immediately
tried bilotti redist this midi
cast churches with
also I will let the minister of
account parking have to become because
we are both interested kosmeya would this
system work with great reliability
guarantees interested in wanting to do and
aldis systems agency interfax question
sir packed I am
preparing the
usa to develop military-technical
cooperation with russia in front of my
thanks and in what areas if this time
interfax who else on the ride should be
among here develop cute thirty
copywriting and trembling and long way she you are
from here i can  to see you have a prison on a
swing and show off  you are well
placed
to visit stepan florists
briefly answer yes, but for this, in order to
implement ben technical
cooperation, we need to draw up a
joint statement, and in anticipation of such a
joint statement, I can state that, in
principle, such cooperation is even possible.
especially this
applies to such areas as
theater missile defense
it will be read by your baby doll kinberg
lethargic john [ __ ] pinya
professions as a result of which
significant damage can be caused to both American and Russian troops and
in particular in the process of implementing the
world of creative activities and watering
it was decided not to  became so little jandara in
principle the place is captured and the points in this
rule in the contract hydrotest detachment
around Saint Tropez and given the
massive spread of weapons and
the personal threat from this I think that
we need to work side by side in order
to achieve a joint reduction  ia
such a threat
to lose
a little body and in a pair
.  bears about the growth of the article in
artek, it is precisely the authors who very often
dacha or you or rushed
away for a chance to become his very tone the times
today it was reported that you were against the
ratification of the
start-2 treaty even after an
hour after the changes that occurred at the
summit in helsinki what is your relationship with the
question  about the ratification of sam, the struggle does
not correspond quite well, and at 33,
when I was acting head of the
academy of the general staff and
at the very beginning of the conclusion of this
START-2 agreement, I doubted it
[music]
that
this agreement is
beneficial for Russia, I had a doubt
ayna bastinda bubble  end
of the general staff academy door
molds interfered with the state of shell-shocked from with the document
start to live and ayat itself to us about you
saw yes and erase that rush but then when the
process of our cooperation went
further along the path of deepening the
expansion especially trust
[music]
were signed  certain
agreement documents on the development of our
relationship to the military field and when the
President  we
met in Helsinki and went further, we
already discussed the issue of the possibility of
considering
with star 3 or START-3, I
already didn’t have it in my return on START 2, and
vice versa, I’m trying to convince the
leaders
on the neck of the
committees’ thoughts, first of all, the defense committee about
what is
needed as much as possible  rather ratify the
treaty and su-22 with dps and could belong in
death and a number of documents and
between our sites and
and special of today i'll sing me think of
all the president's and
muffs all down the body's eat you and now
i  'm a great supporter of a start to
live here and mdf is impossible to convince
powers hurried indus and defence to the media of
the state duma you vote for this
document
blocks she im warm condensate
yes your kin in sur vie security of our
country and van baelsar number of a mi
sales and walked
azeta today mr
.
correspondent from today
newspapers in his date a great
attention was significant he yes
and shoes of destruction and force of yours
and can you be more specific about you and the
bees hey twitch america kent jumps into the
core in die form of consultations our
experience a couch  in this field
guide lumberjack, in general, they will deduct you from the
year old of their congress
and I myself will probably help me with
rodionova convince the Russian home and for the
closure of military bases and we in congress
should probably do the same,
but I answer briefly  I know how much the
American nation has done
reformed its armed forces
since  war in vietnam
hamil by boni short on all die for you
move cottage cheese you che america nation and sail
one reefs from the andes for this auto
parsing indeed call us so the consequences of the
cold war for us now as for
you the war in vietnam
wild sequencer he took the count dwarf  since they
are equal to die consequences of warfare stains,
this is not only the reduction of the armed
forces itself, although this is the basis of the reform,
it's not only the down side and for cis,
but a qualitative improvement of the channel, then the reforms
and the cycle of the neighboring one,
for example, I will give you an example,
as you put it awkwardly  as an
example, we have absolutely no
institute of sergeants in the army for example of
another army come out he is a clear institute of
in seoul but of course the office I know what
strong sti here
sergeants in the united states armed forces
he is to fight and ah know how strong
is in seoul to andy and  on those states army and
I am very interested in the training system for
a md match interstitch internet jean
syoss and on 3 this is the farce itself  and
also we are reducing, we continue to reduce,
and
we need
to somehow retrain the
officers and other military personnel dismissed from the army
in the cantina near ida, because the
dakshina of officer's indian forces and
we need you with finding the adapter for
so very onlive and the United States are already
showing us in solving this  the issue of
certain assistance and specifics in the 10-cylinder
concrete bar assistance in
this field
technical re-equipment
technician standardization and unification only
unify keysha armament technology you have
great experience in unitex novelty we still
adopt black granite experience and so on
many many new things about saw
which
in solving which  can help
armed forces kindergarten that with a blow mini
and problems and
states channel of phrases and we will be grateful
and forth
wizards
flew curie briefing question with learn to
form their interest
also the fight will be conducted by britain 1 tess
courier who has not yet reached the
heights of the press and
influx band phone data expert for whole
nights still andre  her express
custom example forces in for
more us
so that the viking files of the
complex are turned into the axis itself, he will certainly be able to
use our experience in
reforming and restructuring the
armed forces in order to make
the same conclusions when carrying out his
deus ex eis reforms
with you and your defense minister